copyrighting books that are guaranteed
to make you filthy rich cash vertising
by far the most tactical approach to
becoming insanely persuasive in your
copyrighting breakthrough advertising
this book is 60 years old and is still
regarded as the golden standard for
understanding human behavior the ad week
copywriting handbook if I'd start
anywhere I'd start here oal V on
Advertising this is incredible for big
picture thinking the copywriters
handbook for everything modern like
website Ling Pages sales Pages Facebook
ads Google ads
infotainment jackpot this one teaches
you how to turn your boring nobody wants
to read your stuff copy into exciting
gets people's blood pumping wants to
read your copy kick ass copywriting the
only book that I would read if you are
focused on sales letters and vsls